Comment rendre magique une petite cuillère ?
L'inox dont sont faits la plupart de nos
couvert n'est pas le plus joli des métaux,
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui on va le sublimer
en le faisant briller. Pour cela je vais
avoir besoin d'un briquet ou d'allumettes,
d'une bougie, d'un verre d'eau, d'une cuillère
en inox et d'une seringue ou d'un robinet.
On  va commencer par allumer la bougie avec le
briquet ou les allumettes.
Puis on va passer  le dos de la cuillère sur cette bougie jusqu'à ceque le dos soit complètement recouvert de noir.
Voilà chose faite !
On va ensuite mettre un petit  peu d'eau dans la seringue ou toutsimplement faire couler le robinet.
Et maintenant on va faire couler au goutte
à goutte de l'eau sur le dos de la cuillère
Et on observe que au lieu
de couler dessus les petites
gouttes d'eau rebondissent
sur le dos de la cuillère.
Pareil lorsque l'on met la cuillère dans
l'eau la surface est complètement brillante,
là où la cuillère était devenu noire,
alors que le reste n'est pas trèsbrillant.
Qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Lacouche noire sur le dos de la cuillère,
après l'avoir passé sur la flamme est dela suie, de la poudre de carbone très fine.
La suie est hydrophobe, c'est-à-dire qu'elle
repousse l'eau, donc quand la cuillère est
mis sous le robinet l'eau ne peut pas
s'étaler et couler dessus normalement.
A la place l'eau rebondie, idem quand la cuillère
est plongée dans le verre. L' eau longe la suie sans la mouiller.
L'eau ne s'attache pas à la suie.
Cela forme une surface lisse qui renvoie la
lumière exactement comme un miroir, la cuillère
brille sous l'eau. Lorsque la terre est sèche
et qu'il pleut la pluie rebondie parfois sur
le sol de la même manière que sur la suie de
la cuillère. C'est dû à une autre poudre
présente sur terre et que tu connais très
bien, la poussière. La poussière repousse l'eau,
comme la suie elle est hydrophobe.
Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode ! Je t'invite à refaire cette expérience chez toi avec un adulte, le feu ça brûle.
Et te donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour répondre à une nouvelle question.